joined by the one and only Scott a Arco
the president and CEO of Silver State
Schools Credit Union welcome back to the
show Scott I gotta ask you this is such
a great program that Silver State
Schools Credit Union has put together
they have a long-standing scholarship
program how many scholarships are
available on this yep um since 1989
silver States Coast Credit Union has
awarded over one million dollars in
scholarships to deserving High School
seniors and we're really happy to
announce that our 2023 scholarship
program is now available and so through
our people over profit Foundation we
have 10 scholarship recipients and
they'll each be awarded a two thousand
dollar scholarship and by the way that's
renewable for up to four years and so
that's for a total of eight thousand
dollars per recipient and really the
goal is to promote higher education
learning and build our future leaders
for Southern Nevada I love that you guys
do this how much does silver state
Schools Credit Union award in
scholarships every year great question
Mercedes once again through our people
over profit Foundation Silver State
Schools Credit Union Awards twenty
thousand dollars to the ten chosen
recipients uh for the school year and
since our scholarships are renewable for
four years approximately eighty thousand
dollars is uh awarded in scholarship
funds each year wow I was I was looking
over some of the criteria that you had
for the scholarships and I noticed that
you offer a teacher-specific scholarship
what is that all about yep I'm glad you
asked I think that's a really important
one
um so Mercedes Silver State Schools
Credit Union offers a scholarship that's
really focus on students who intend to
major in education and become a teacher
since we we still have a huge Nationwide
uh teacher shortage and and absolutely
one here in southern Nevada and so
um so we recognize the increasing need
for teachers here in southern Nevada so
we want to do our best to support that
uh for up and coming Educators and and
so we're doing our best to create that
program and uh for them I love that you
guys do that so the magic question how
do students apply for this yep I'm glad
yes so high school seniors can find the
scholarship application and complete
details at Silver
statecu.com backslash scholarships and
that application deadline is uh Friday
March 24th and so again
soberstatecu.com backslash scholarships
don't let this opportunity pass you by
seniors or parents of seniors it is a
great program Scott thank you so great
to talk to you today thank you so much
Mercedes always good to talk to you too
thank you Silver State Schools Credit
Union for sponsoring this segment you
can give them a call at
702-733-8820 or visit silverstatecu.com